this episode is brought to you by magic
spoon magic spoon is a brand new cereal
that i eat just about every day that is
low carb high protein and zero
sugar i just ate a huge bowl of their
cocoa flavor
about an hour ago after a short workout
magic spoon cereal
has received a lot of attention since
launching last year
time magazine included it in their list
of best inventions of 2019
and forbes called it the future of
cereal it tastes just like your favorite
sugary cereal from childhood remember
that
but it's actually good for you each
serving has 11 grams of protein
3 grams of net carbs 0 grams of sugar
and only 110 calories it's also gluten
free grain free keto friendly soy free
and
gmo free all the things it's delicious
and i don't say that lightly because
most of this healthy
version of x stuff is not delicious but
these guys really nail it magic spoon
has nailed it it comes in your favorite
traditional
cereal flavors like cocoa frosted and
blueberry you can try them all by
grabbing a variety pack
at magicspoon.comtim or you can just
grab a box
or a bunch of boxes i'm going to order
some more today of the coco which is my
personal favorite but there is a new
contender for favorite flavor because
they just
launched two limited edition flavors
honey nut and peanut butter which are
delicious i am a sucker for peanut
butter
and it is outstanding so i think cocoa
and peanut butter are my two new
favorite flavors and fun fact
my friends are also obsessed with magic
spoon one of the podcasts
most popular guest dr peter tia
routinely crushes six to seven servings
at a time that's a lot
with no glycemic response he's looked at
this with a glucometer
he likes it so much he invested other
friends two
very fine gentlemen and also past
podcast guests kevin rose and ryan
holiday
also invested so go to magicspoon.com
tim to grab some delicious cereal and
try it for yourself today
use promo code tim that's tim at
checkout to save five dollars off of
your order
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product i have boxes and boxes and boxes
it's backed
with a 100 percent happiness guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund
your money no questions asked get your
next delicious bowl
of guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
tim and use the code tim to get five
dollars off
episode is brought to you by eight sleep
my god am i in love with eight sleep
good sleep is the ultimate game changer
more than 30 percent of americans
struggle with sleep
and i'm a member of that sad group
temperature is one of the main causes of
poor sleep and heat has always been my
nemesis
i've suffered for decades tossing and
turning throwing blankets off putting
them back on and repeating ad nauseam
but now
i am falling asleep in record time
faster than ever why
because i'm using a simple device called
the pod pro
cover by eight sleep it's the easiest
and fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature
it pairs dynamic cooling and heating
with biometric tracking to offer the
most advanced
but most user-friendly solution on the
market
i polled all of you guys on social media
about the best tools
for sleep enhancing sleep and
aidsleep was by far and away the crowd
favorite i mean people were just
raving fans of this so i used it and
here we are
add the pod pro cover to your current
mattress and start sleeping
as cool as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as
hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit
it also splits your bed in half so your
partner can choose a totally different
temperature
my girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need
cooling she loves the heat and we can
have our own bespoke temperatures on
either side which is exactly what we're
doing
now for me and for many people the
result eight sleep users fall asleep up
to 32
faster reduce sleep interruptions by up
to 40
and get more restful sleep overall i can
personally attest to this because i
track it in all sorts of ways
it's the total solution for enhanced
recovery so you can take on the next day
feeling refreshed and now my dear
listeners that's you guys
you can get two hundred and fifty
dollars off of the pod pro cover that's
a lot
simply go to eight sleep dot com slash
tim
or use code tim that's eight all spelled
out
e-i-g-h-t sleep dot com
slash tim or use coupon code tim
t-i-m eight sleep dot com slash tim
for two hundred dollars off your pod pro
cover
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal questions
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
tim ferriss show you know i haven't even
noted that my standard intro says germs
over and over and over again
that may be a bit of foreshadowing for
some of our discussion today
nonetheless my job normally is to
interview world-class performers of all
different types
and in some cases better still to
interview people who have
studied many world-class performers and
that is certainly the case
today my guest is for the second time on
the podcast
walter isaacson walter is a professor of
history at tulane has been ceo of the
aspen institute
chair of cen and editor of time he is
the author of
many books you will no doubt recognize
leonardo da vinci the innovators steve
jobs einstein subtitle his life in
universe benjamin franklin
an american life and kissinger's
subtitle a biography his co-author of
the wise men six friends and the world
they made his new book is the code
breaker
subtitle jennifer doudna believe i'm
getting that right d-o-u-d-n-a
gene editing and the future of the human
race you can find our first conversation
from 2017
at team.log forward slash walter he did
a spectacular job
and you can find much more about him at
isaacsoni s a a c
s o n.tulane.edu walter welcome back
to the show hey it's great to be back
with you tim
and i have no shortage of material as
usual we covered a lot of your
personal biographical information many
of your
practices writing process etc in our
last conversations so i i won't spend a
lot of time on that people can listen to
our first
chat if they want to dive into those
topics but
i'm going to ask a few questions before
we get into
talking about crispr and jennifer and so
many other things
and the three questions are going to be
and these are my shorthand notes in
front of me
bio of louis armstrong why not then
the second is professor and i may have
asked you this already but i want to ask
again because i'm curious
professor why meaning how did you decide
to
on top of or and in addition to
everything else that you do become a
professor of history
and then third just because i want to
give people a teaser
chinese crisper babies how
so there's the why not the why and the
how so
you you have so many books you have
completed
i i honestly just am constantly
impressed
at how much not just work but
high quality writing you produce
so i'm curious about the survivorship
bias right so could you please speak
to the bio of
louis armstrong or the the would-be bio
of louis
armstrong well any performance i have it
comes from reading your books tim so
thanks and thanks for having me on the
show
i learn peak performance and i try hard
to get up to about
10 percent of what you say i should be
able to do but sometimes you have to put
something aside
leonardo da vinci knew that because he
only finished
12 full paintings and put ones aside
that he couldn't get
perfect and i had to do that once with a
biography of louis armstrong
i'm here in new orleans my hometown i
wanted to write about the birth of jazz
and louis armstrong and race and growing
up in new orleans in the early 20th
century
and i listened to all of the recordings
he did the tapes he did
of discussions i read all of his notes
and his letters i went to corona queens
where there's a lewis armstrong museum
and after a while i felt i knew
everything there was to know about louis
armstrong
except for who he was i didn't know why
he was smiling
i didn't know if he's happy i didn't
know if he really liked white people or
you know whether his best friend who you
know was his white manager
was somebody he didn't like and i
realized that if you cannot crack
the code you're better off not writing
the book
are there other subjects you've
considered i'm sure there must be
and begun to work on only to put aside
like so many paintings of da vinci's
well you know i
did ada lovelace who in the 1840s and
1850s comes up with the concept of the
computer
algorithm and she's the first chapter in
the last chapter of my book
the innovators and i had tried or
considered
making an entire biography of her i went
up oxford university
with her letters she was the daughter of
lord byron her letters are part of the
byron papers there
but unfortunately there just wasn't
enough
to make a full-length biography so i
used her as the framing device
for the innovators we're going to come
back to ada
i because i i i want to use that
as a device for perhaps introducing
a number of topics that we'll we'll
we'll revisit later
but so we've checked the why not
on uh loose armstrong in the bio thereof
professor i'd love to just take a few
minutes to chat about this this is
probably not where
people are going to start as they chat
with you about the new book but
i would just love to know the thought
process how did that
come to be since you have so many
options on the table you have so many
things you could do
and i'm not saying it's a bad choice i
love
students i love teaching i feel i learn
more from them and they can learn from
me
i have this incredible class at tulane
of of students who study the history of
the
digital revolution and by the end of the
class they're teaching me more as i try
to figure out
all right do i want to join clubhouse
what do we do on discord how can
you create a social network for gamers
so i love
the stimulation you get from teaching
students
secondly and this will happen to a lot
of people
i was ready to go home i was born and
raised in new orleans my parents my
grandparents
went to tulane i wanted to go back where
i could
you know be part of my roots get a
little bit grounded again
after a life of being you know at cnn or
aspen institute and the way for me
was to go home where i've known kids
since
kindergarten who are my close friends to
teach their kids and grandkids at tulane
and to help that process of saying
how can we make things better for the
next generation
what is home i know you answered this in
part already but what does home mean to
you
because for some people home is
say the first city outside of their
birthplace
where they reside for an extended period
after college for instance
home can mean different things to
different people what is it what is it
that keeps drawing you back
well i'm extraordinarily lucky because
some people don't have
a particular birthplace or home that
they're deeply
connected to but i wake up every morning
with a
sense of gratitude in a way that i have
a community
where i was born and raised that's still
here in new orleans
and you know they've known me since i
was a kid i've got a lot of family here
and new orleans is a city that is
extraordinarily creative
as you know i mean this is what your
podcast is about
it's also got challenges like every city
it's an incredibly diverse
city and so i found myself
coming home especially after hurricane
katrina i was asked to be
the vice chair of the recovery authority
after that
storm and i realize how
badly i miss new orleans but also how
immersing yourself in a place of great
diversity
with people who have some frictions and
challenge you
but also people have known you your
whole life so you can't
you know you got to be true to who you
are because they'll cut you right down
if you're not all of that
gave me a sense of grounding and
it also gave me the sense which i think
is probably the most important lesson
and you've written about it but so many
other people have
which is if you wake up every morning
and realize how lucky you are you will
be
a happier and more creative person and
that
can extend even the people have had a
whole lot of challenges in their life
and for me when i wake up in new orleans
i think
man you know i'm lucky
the wear of happiness the wear of
feeling at home as obvious as that might
seem
is just so under
estimated i feel at least i
underestimated it for
decades certainly i felt like i should
be able
to be fill in the blank fill in the
blank
in any location what do you call home
you know
my home is not too far from you it is
now
austin texas it has been for the last uh
three to four years now probably closer
to four years
and uh when we when we managed to
navigate through this this current
pandemic and get
to some semblance of the other side of
the tunnel
then we should have a proper cup of
coffee in person
and it's very close to new orleans both
spiritually and physically
in the sense that they're both places
with great music
great university towns great diversity
and you know great creativity so i love
going to austin i go there all the time
my brother went to ut
and certainly during the hurricane
katrina we all evacuated there for a
while
well you and i if if i may be so bold
she'll have
she'll have should have may have i would
love to have a coffee
it's been a while it's been a while and
i'm glad you brought up music
because new orleans showcases
a beautiful art form that many know as
jazz
and that is in a sense a byproduct of
diversity
of one might say randomness of one might
say
mutation so as a metaphor i think
that that will also play into a lot of
what we discuss
and that is my attempt at a segway to
chinese crispr babies
so what on earth am i talking about
what do i mean by chinese crispr babies
are we cook
are we cooking babies what is this what
is christmas so two years ago
in china a doctor who had been to some
of the seminars
by my the hero of my new book jennifer
doudna
had decided to use this technique that
jennifer doudna and her partner emanuel
sharpen j
invented for which they won the nobel
prize in october
and that that technique is called crispr
and it's based on something bacteria
have been doing for a billion years
which is keeping track of viruses that
attack them
and then using a scissors to cut up
those viruses if they attack again
we can imagine that's pretty useful in
these days of pandemic
but what jennifer doudna did was figure
out a way to
turn that into a tool that could edit
our own genes in other words if you
wanted to
edit yourself so that you didn't have
sickle cell anemia
that could be done with this tool called
crispr and it's already been done
the interesting thing somewhat
controversial but in some ways very
promising
is we can edit our children we can
create what is sometimes called
designer babies by saying when they're
embryos early stage embryos or even
reproductive cells we can say let's take
out
the gene that would allow you to get
sickle cell anemia or hunting disease
or cystic fibrosis so that our children
will be genetically healthier what
happened two years ago
is that for the very first time in a way
that was
unauthorized a scientist in china
did that he edited the embryos which
turned out to be
two twin girls and edited out
the receptor that allows them
to get the virus that causes aids
and there was an immediate outburst of
awe and then some shock
because the world wasn't quite ready
it's like prometheus snatching fire from
the gods or adam and eve biting into the
apple or something
the world wasn't quite ready for us to
be
editing our children and creating
designer babies
but that's what my book is about which
is
when should we be allowed to edit
our children when should we be allowed
to add or
take away genetic traits from the human
species
and when would that be dangerous to do
so
or perhaps even immoral to do so
i love interviewing you man you're so
good at this i just really enjoy it
and uh i uh connected yourself
thank you thank you it's a work in
progress
maybe after maybe after another five
hundred he'll also that goes back to
chris for the whole human species is a
work in progress
let's not forget that and thank god i
can edit my interviews
so that i sound better uh the double
helix
the double helix i want to talk about a
little bit of your history first
and then we're going to make a very easy
transition to the protagonist of
your story when did you first
get exposed to the double helix the book
and what is this book for those who
don't know when i was in middle school
my father gave me a copy of james
watson's book the double helix i just
found it recently down here in new
orleans
it has the pale red cover it was
published in the early 1960s and it's
the description
of how james watson and his partner
francis crick
used some of the data by rosalind
franklin and
raced against people like linus pauling
to be
able to discover the structure
of dna and it was like a detective story
it was about
how does life work what is the secret of
life
how do genes work and i remember reading
that
and because i still look in the margins
i could probably sell it on ebay it's a
first edition of the book
but in the margin or all my you know
childhood scribblings defining words i
didn't know
like biochemistry and i decided that's
really cool and ever since then
i've had an interest in understanding
the
the joy of understanding how something
works especially when that something is
our own selves so the protagonist
the main character as it were you've
chosen
to spend so much time on
how did you choose her well jennifer
doudna
was somebody i'd heard speak out at the
aspen institute which i know you know
well and others about how
they had developed this tool to edit
human genes and how powerful it be
in giving us you know healthier lives
fighting cancer fighting
coronavirus it turns out and how it can
make our species
healthier but there was some dangers to
that and at one point
i was talking to her i said how did you
get interested in it
and she said you know i was just in
sixth grade
growing up in hilo hawaii i was sort of
an outsider because i was she's a tall
lanky blonde girl but
it was in a small village in hawaii and
everybody else was polynesian
and so she felt kind of a loner and she
came home one day
and she said my dad had left on my
bed a copy of this book by james watson
called the double helix and i went oh
wow
my dad did that as well and she said
that's when i decided i wanted to become
a scientist i read about rosalind
franklin in there
and i thought well i didn't realize
women could become scientists and
she asked her high school guidance
counselor and the guidance counselor
said no
girls don't become scientists and that
made jennifer doubt and decide that she
would be
a scientist it also made me decide i was
going to write about jennifer dowd
because she did what maybe i should have
done
after reading the double helix was say
i want to be a research scientist so
to just
allow a preview of the other side of the
coin
if we could and this is just how my mind
works jumping around
we've talked a bit about the
the possible promises of
crispr this gene editing pair of
scissors that allows you to do wondrous
things
uh previously unimaginable what are some
of the risks
you alluded to that is there a danger
for instance
of customized bio weapons that could be
targeted
at specific populations are there other
things
that you could mention in brief as as
real possible risks
of this technology because it is as i
understand at least
a all things considered very inexpensive
accessible
technology it is not something that is
relegated to the best funded governments
for instance about a year
after jennifer doudna developed this
crispr
gene editing tool she had a nightmare
and the nightmare was that she had been
asked to meet somebody who wanted to
understand the tool and she walks into
the room
and the person looks up and it's adolf
hitler
and she realizes that if this technology
like almost any technology
falls into the wrong hands it could be
used for nefarious purposes
the ones you mentioned like military or
obvious ones you could make
a virus you know using crispr or some
bacteria using crispr that was even
deadlier than the
coronavirus that pandemic we're going
through now
you could create as vladimir putin said
about a year ago super soldiers that are
stronger
and resistant to radiation if you want
to fight wars
so that's one thing that could happen
another thing that could happen
is that we decide to make designer
babies and design our children
and let's say that you and i decide we
want to make sure our children don't
have any bad genetic disease like cystic
fibrosis
or multiple sclerosis or tay sachs or
huntington's disease or sickle cell
that's pretty good you and i would say
that's a good thing for us to be able to
edit to make sure our children don't
have that but let's say at the fertility
clinic they also say to you would you
want to make them a little bit taller
or have muscle mass there's an easy gene
that at a certain point growing up
starts slowing down our growth of muscle
mass you could suppress that gene
and have children that were much
stronger and then
maybe you could affect their memory to
have them have a much better memory
or have them you know have blue eyes
you could change a lot of things and
that leads to a lot of questions
one of which is should we let the rich
buy better genes for their kids because
these offerings at the genetic
supermarket
they're not going to be free and what
would that do to the diversity of our
species you and i talk about the joy of
wandering the streets
of austin texas or new orleans and we
see people
tall and skinny you know light and dark
and gay and straight and trans
and all sorts of traits that they have
it's hard to edit some complex traits
but a few decades from now we'll be able
to edit out traits that somehow another
we feel we're we don't prefer having in
our children
well that could be dangerous for the
species and for our society
and for people who want to get a visual
on what it might look like to use crispr
to
enhance muscularity you can look up now
this is not crispr
necessarily because breeding certainly
can achieve
what crispr does just takes a lot longer
the belgian blue
breed of beef cattle is
bred for hyperplasia which is increased
number of muscle fibers there may be
some myostatin inhibition also but
people can look at that or bully whip it
if you want to see a whippet you might
envision a very skinny
tiny little dog very wiry pretty
neurotic looking not saying they're
neurotic if you on one
and then you add twice or three times
the muscle mass
it's pretty shocking certainly
impressive
to see and it's very possible you know
the gene
for myostatin suppression after a while
you know the myostatin reduces and so
you quit building more muscle mass
that's a pretty easy gene to knock out
using crispr and that's indeed what
happens
with double muscling cattle which you
just described
and so they're truly wondrous things we
could do especially
you know helping people who have some
disabilities
uh to make them stronger or better so
before we get scared about crispr we
have to realize
it can do truly wonderful things just
this past year
a woman named victoria gray living in
mississippi
was cured of sickle cell anemia the
first time you've had a pure cure
using crispr this is a fantastic
introduction in a sense connection to
the question i was going to ask
because there are lots of athletes who
listen to this and many trainers and
coaches and so on
and that was whether crispr can be
applied to adults or if it has to be
applied at the embryonic stage
or the very early stages of life and you
seem to have just answered that
let me tell you about a guy named jason
zainer by the way who lives
in austin now moved from the bay area of
california
and he's a biohacker and he
has ability to use crispr and you know
sort of cooked it up in his own lab he's
a phd
but he does it you know in his basement
as a biohacker
and he has created a way
to use crispr to suppress a bit of the
myostatin
issue and maybe increase his muscles and
he
did it live on a live stream video
injecting himself with it now it didn't
really work you can't
do it with just one shot but he's one of
those
pioneers that shows what citizen science
can do
and eventually yes athletes could be
able
to help increase their muscle mass or
for that matter their quick reflexes the
twitch
muscles all these sort of things and so
that's going to be interesting uh you
know we put a little asterisks next to
you know maguire or conseco or people
who use steroids
but what if your genes give you better
athletic ability do we go from admiring
the athlete to
admiring their genetic engineer and what
if you could do that in your children so
they
are born with genes that give them
faster muscle twitch or higher muscles
and they can
bend steel with their bare hands you
know that's going to be
both a great opportunity but also a real
challenge
good luck anti-doping committees this is
going to be very challenging
they're already resource constrained
do not envy that boy sports are going to
get very
also with gender identity i mean not to
get into that topic but
sports are going to become very very
complicated increasingly so over the
over the next decade now i i have
in front of me a note and i'm just going
to give you a
[Music]
fragment of it that i would love for you
to expand upon
and that is the three
fundamental kernels of our existence the
atom
the bit and the gene could i give that
to you as a cue and let you run with it
when i was writing my books i thought of
what are the great
innovation revolutions there have been
three of them and they start with those
fundamental kernels of our existence
that were sort of discovered around 1900
which is the atom and then the notion
that
all information can be encoded in binary
digits
but we now call bits and finally the
gene
and so when i wrote about einstein it
was about innovation in the first half
of the 20th century
based on the theories about the atom
everything from atom bombs to space
travel to semiconductors to lasers
all come that innovation revolution from
that discoveries of physics the second
half of the 20th century when you and i
were growing up
was the information technology
revolution the digital revolution
based on the encoding of all information
in bits
the creation of computers that could
manipulate those bits
and the creation of an internet or
networks that could transmit
those bits the next great revolution
is now and it's based on the gene
it's based on the fact that all of us
and our kids who had to learn
digital coding we'll also have to learn
genetic
coding because the molecule
is going to become the new microchip
it's going to allow us to
innovate to fight coronaviruses to edit
our own
genes to fight cancer i use jennifer
doudna as the central character
to say what happens when we get to the
third great revolution of our time
and it's based on us
our own molecules our own cells our own
genes
do you hope this book will inspire
new generations of scientists in the way
that the double helix
did for jennifer doudna is that one of
the motivations
absolutely i would hope that people will
read this book
and they'll admire the nobility of what
research scientists do
of course that was sort of a a goal of
mine four or five years ago when i
started working on it
now after these scientists have created
vaccines that are going to get us out of
this
coronavirus pandemic i think people are
primed
to say hey i admire people who are in
the life sciences and figuring out
how we can create a healthier species
but i also hope after reading the book
they might leave it on the bed
of you know some student in high school
and
hope that they will be inspired to
either
love science or maybe even be a
researcher
in science because there's a joy in
figuring out how something works
especially
when that something is ourselves so i
want people
to feel more connected to science i want
them to feel less intimidated by science
because
sometimes when you're you know don't
like vaccines or you don't like the
internet or whatever
it's because you don't you're
intimidated by the mysteries of it
and so i want to demystify it and so
that real
people like jennifer doudna wake up in
the morning
and they do simple i mean crispr is
pretty simple it's just three components
they do simple experiments and they're
able to do things that will affect
our lives and i want people who are
you know kids or raising kids to say you
got to be part
not only of the digital generation but
the biotech generation
even if you're not going to be a
scientist you're going to have to be
part of the conversation
that says how are we going to use these
new technologies to create
vaccines to fight cancers to make
healthier babies
what are going to be the rules of the
road and in order to be
part of that discussion it's kind of
helpful
to know what it's all about
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
linkedin jobs the new year is here
and it marks a fresh start for your
small business whether you're shifting
business hours or hiring more remote
employees
one thing that remains unchanged is the
importance of having the right people on
your team
when your business is ready to make that
next hire linkedin jobs can help by
matching your role with qualified
candidates so you can find
the right person quickly and to lend a
helping hand
your first job post is free getting
started is easier than ever with new
features to help you find qualified
candidates quickly
from linkedin's active community of
professionals with more than 722 million
members
worldwide post a job with targeted
screening questions
to get your role in front of more
qualified candidates you can manage
job posts and contact candidates on the
familiar linkedin.com website
where functions are streamlined into one
simple screen
and now you can do all this from your
mobile device no matter where the day
takes you
when your business is ready to make that
next hire find the right person with
linkedin jobs and now you can post a job
for
free just visit linkedin.com slash tim
again that's linkedin.com
tim to post a job for free terms and
conditions do
apply
you mentioned just a moment ago or you
you uttered a line
that i wrote down because i i quite like
it and that is the molecule will become
the new microchip
and we're talking about biotech
generations and perhaps the differences
between
what we consider coding education
or even just passing coding familiarity
knowing the
the high level concepts even if you are
not a coder yourself and it makes me
think of a conversation i'm not going to
mention this person by name because i
don't think this was public but
very well known co-founder of a large
company everyone would
recognize who is very involved with
conversations around
the promises or potentials and threats
of artificial intelligence
and before he has a conversation with
anyone about ai
he asks them if they have studied
computer science
question number one and number two if
they have kids and if they can't answer
yes to both of those he just refuses to
have the conversation
uh because and the having kids is
relevant because
it i think forces in many people a
longer term
perspective and a longer time horizon
for considering the consequences of
certain things
so if someone i'm just saying
this hypothetically now or five years
ago
would have been put into sort of
computer science 101
with learning who knows what i'm not a
coder but
you know ruby or pearl or god knows what
language they end up learning at some
point
what does the education look like
for someone who wants to better
understand the molecule
as the new microchip actually i think
it's even
simpler i think that the molecule
and the life science is something we all
more intuitively
understand certainly when you do
computer science it's not about ruby or
ruby on rails or perl script or anything
like that
it's about the algorithm it's about
thinking sequentially
step by step logically so that you can
do a computer program
that's the important thing you have to
grok if you're
are going to understand how computers
work but with the life sciences with you
know genetic coding
it's simply that you have to understand
that
we have three billion base pairs of
letters
in our dna you don't have to know them
you don't have to read you know the
human genome project
study you just have to know that certain
segments of these encode what we call
a gene we're now able to map
on our dna a lot of those genes
the genes that do simple things like
cause sickle cell anemia or cause blue
eyes
and the question becomes logically
how can you do things that makes
use of the molecules in our body
to create things that we want
such as antibodies to fight a
virus or to stop
your blood from creating sickle cells
that are dangerous so i don't think you
need to know the four letters of dna
or the similar but slightly different
four letters of rna
but you do need to know that dna encodes
our genes
and then rna is actually the cooler
molecule it actually does some work it
doesn't just curate information
it takes that information and goes to
the manufacturing region
of our cells and builds a protein
and you say okay what type of proteins
do we want
antibodies for a virus let's build that
proteins that will make our blood
healthier let's do that
and so just this general concept
of how our bodies work i think is useful
whether you're an
athlete or a creative person or just
somebody who wants to be part of society
and it's not that complicated you don't
need to know a whole lot of boolean
algebra or math
in order to do life sciences you just
need to know this central dogma of
biology
that our genes turn rna
into worker bees that build proteins in
our cells
okay now what are we going to do with
that i think many of these
toolkits right whether it's familiarity
with the algorithms right in some
respects the recipes of computer science
or those types of technologies
and then biochemical or genetic
fluency i think that those will very
often go
increasingly hand in hand right i i was
looking at a list
earlier today from 2007 which was
one of those lists you see a lot right
the hundred greatest living geniuses
and this is from 2007. one must keep in
mind because
we have someone at least one has passed
away i think tim berners-lee is still
with us but the first place this is from
the daily telegraph so think what you
may have the daily telegraph the the
first place
position was tied between tim
berners-lee
who is i suppose best
known as a computer scientist who
was one of the inventors or co-inventors
of the world wide web brilliant man
and yes he is still living i just
confirmed and albert hoffman
a name people may not recognize who was
the first person to synthesize
lsd-25 also psilocybin and many other
things like hydrogen which is used for
cognitive function and age-related
dementia
so you have a computer scientist and a
chemist
side by side and i think that's just
going to increasingly be the case you
mentioned proteins we're going to have
protein folding and how proteins fold is
a is a big problem that that computers
do
very well with but let's let's move to
the personal
jennifer doudna there are few phrases
that i picked out of what you said
nobility of scientists so there are
noble scientists and then there are
ignoble scientists
simple experiments what made
what makes jennifer special
right because there are a lot of
scientists and just like in the
in the field of medicine where like p
equals md is a joke among a lot of my
doctor friends pass equals
medical doctor in other words there's
the kind of good the bad and the ugly so
what
makes her special you know you write a
lot about performance
and creativity and i have found that the
simplest component of it is curiosity
you know jennifer doudna was
persistently
obsessively and joyfully curious even
growing up in hawaii
she'd touch a piece of what's called
sleeping grass and it would curl up
and she kept wondering why does that
happen why does it curl and she'd look
at the spirals of the seashells and
she'd say
how does an animal create that and when
i saw that she was doing that i realized
leonardo da vinci did the same thing
with spirals
and shells and curls and trying to
figure it out and you can see it even in
the mona lisa her curls
so that curiosity about everyday things
like i'm looking out now in new orleans
and there's the bluest of blue skies
people who are curious say well why is a
sky blue
leonardo da vinci asked that einstein
asked it
and jennifer doudna asked questions like
that so
not outgrowing our wonder years being
able to stay relentlessly curious
that's what caused jennifer doudna to
keep saying
all right i've just seen this thing but
how does it
really work what's inside
of our bodies of our molecules of our
cells
that causes this to work and she
discovers
some of the key clues of how things work
one of which is
the structure of molecules how the
structure of rna
allows it to build certain proteins
and so i think if i were to say how can
you be creative as a scientist or for
that matter
as a musician or athlete it would be be
curious about everything
all walks of life arts and sciences
technology and humanities
that's what steve jobs did he had one
foot in the arts
another foot in technology and he did
not make a distinction
between those two that's what leonardo's
vitruvian man
is about it's a work of art and it's a
work of science
and he didn't make a distinction between
those two and for jennifer
doudna she doesn't make a great
distinction
between the life sciences and the
humanities
and by being curious about all things
she's able to
see the patterns in nature
i'd love for you to to comment a bit
more on this
particular species of curiosity
the reason i ask is that there are
many scientists out there and there
are many diligent hard-working
scientists out there
but very few are able to achieve what
jennifer and her collaborators have been
able to
achieve furthermore i would say that
science is great for a lot of things the
scientific method is excellent for
testing hypotheses it doesn't really
offer you
a fail-safe way of generating good
hypotheses right
so was she just asking better questions
i'd love to hear you comment on any
or all of that she asked better
questions
but most importantly she cared about
curiosity driven science what we call
basic scientists
sometimes scientists and for that matter
people
in the world of tech are always keeping
their eye
on the application how can i make
something useful
right how can i make money out of it my
book
is about a group of scientists who
discover
the natural phenomenon of crispr which
is just
a basic science curiosity which is
hey i've looked at bacteria
and they have clustered repeated
sequences in their dna that's hard to
explain
those clustered repeated sequences get
dubbed crisper
nobody was looking to create a gene
editing tool
and initially they weren't looking for
things like how do we protect
yogurt cultures from being attacked by
viruses although it turns out to be
useful for that
they were driven by curiosity pure
curiosity to pursue basic science
and then the applications follow
one day jennifer doudna has finally
cracked the code
of how crispr works in bacteria to fight
off viruses
and she makes it work in a test tube so
that it can
cut a piece of dna at a designated spot
that experiment was done just out of
basic
science research curiosity but the
minute they succeeded they looked at
themselves in the lab and they said
this could be a tool to edit our genes
so the advice is don't always look for
how it's going to be applied
be curious about the basic science and
at some point
the usefulness and the applications will
follow
you have written about
profiled acted as biographer of
quite a few people if you had to
compare jennifer to previous subjects
who is she most similar to and and in
what ways
she's most similar to benjamin franklin
because she's curious about a wide
variety of things but then
also and here's a key part of the book i
write about
at a certain point after she has a
nightmare about adolf hitler
she becomes enmeshed in
understanding the moral and policy
implications of what she's done so like
benjamin franklin she's interested in
basic science
but she's also interested in policy
she's interested
in governance and she connects
science and let's remember ben franklin
was a great
scientist i mean he discovers a single
fluid theory of electricity
but having understand the balances and
checks and balances in newtonian physics
and electricity
and the plus minuses and ledgers he
helps create
a constitution that will hold together
for centuries based on checks and
balances
jennifer doudna also applies
her science and her discoveries to how
is it going to affect
the human species and to our national
society
and so that's why i and she's also just
a good person she's
joyful she really cares about other
people some of the people i've written
about have been a bit
strong cups of tea but i think jennifer
doudna and
ben franklin would sit there over a
glass of
ale or a mug of beer and they would
laugh and they would tell jokes and they
would understand the foibles
of their fellow human beings but they
would love them
and so i would love if i could have a
dinner party to have jennifer dowden and
ben franklin there
uh all right we're we're gonna come back
to that because i would like to know
and this is just a bookmark so we're
going to come back to this but
if jennifer is
competitive in any particular ways that
make her
more similar to say a jobs than a
franklin i don't
know the answer to that but i'd be
curious to explore the nature of
scientific competition and how that
factors into the story but before we do
that
i have some cleanup to do we mentioned
ada lovelace
earlier i said i was going to come back
to her so i do want to do that
very quickly because it may relate to
other things we talk about
in our first conversation i think the
wording that came up was that
ada lovelace pushed herself to
understand that a mathematical equation
is just
nature's brush stroke for painting
something in reality i think that is
roughly the wording which is just
incredible
and what i don't think we talked about
which may or may not be relevant to
things in this conversation
is ada lovelace's objection
and how it contrasts with say alan
turing
is is that something you could speak to
yeah alan turing in his famous paper can
machines
think which was written 100 years after
ada lovelace published her notes on the
analytical engine
ada lovelace says machines will be able
to do
anything that can be notated in symbols
they'll be able to process
music and words and numbers and
patterns they'll be able to do
everything except for
originate thought they won't be able to
be
creative and the purpose will be to
marry
our machines to our own human creativity
so she didn't believe in the pursuit of
what we call artificial intelligence
she didn't believe that would be as
fruitful
as the pursuit of what we now call
augmented intelligence the symbiosis
where we connect
machines and humans more closely
and i think that's because she was the
daughter of lord byron but she was a
mathematician
so she had a poetic sensibility where
she could look at a line of her father's
poetry like
she walks in beauty like the night and
visualize it but she could also look at
an
algorithm or a mathematical sequence
and visualize it as well and so this
ability to connect the humanities
to technology that's what she's the
patron
saint of so she
feels we aren't going to get artificial
intelligence we're going to try to get
the symbiosis of human machines
to create augmented intelligence alan
turing is the other school of thought
he refers to that as lady lovelace's
objection
and his paper his famous paper i think
published maybe in 1950
in mind magazine is soon we'll have an
imitation game test and we'll be able to
show
that machines can think in a way that's
indistinguishable from the way
humans can think now you all can debate
all your listeners can debate that
i'm not sure we have an answer i'm not
sure 50 years from now we'll have
a clean answer to those questions oh boy
that's that could be a whole another
podcast maybe it will be uh
so thank you thank you for thank you for
answering that
and it does connect to the
sort of cross-disciplinary
interdisciplinary
lens through which you have attributed
to
jennifer doudna and before we go
specific to jennifer and
and her story and talking about
competition and where
sort of scientific races figure into
this
i just want to ask a question more
broadly about curiosity because
it's one of those it's one of those
words
that i think can probably i haven't done
this but it could probably be
parsed into very different types of
curiosity
and you mentioned asking why and there
are people who are very good at asking
why
and do it in very productive ways there
are investors i know who ask why
three times just as a matter of course
that is just their policy if they're
talking to startup founder to uncover
assumptions that's why they ask why
then there are people who ask why from a
not necessarily skeptical perspective
but a cynical perspective
right and and those lines
of argument don't often or i shouldn't
say don't always lead
to productive places and when you're
speaking to ada lovelace and poetry
i couldn't help but wonder and this is a
leading question of course
does the common breed
of curiosity that we observe and say in
ada
or jennifer or ben franklin entail a
necessary
seeking of wonder or awe is there a
motivation behind the curiosity
that is shared i think it's a seeking
of wonder as you said and most
importantly
it's an open-minded inquiry
as ben franklin would say let the
experiments be made as jennifer
doudna did it wasn't trying to prove
some pre-existing hypothesis it was
let's follow the facts and then let each
experiment we do
inform how we're going to test something
out
we have lost that ability which is at
the core
of both the scientific method and of the
enlightenment that helps create this
country
which is be open-minded don't
have a preconceived hypothesis that
you're trying to prove
have a sense of wonder and a curiosity
to see where the facts lead you
and that's how ben franklin makes a list
of all the facts he's discovered about
sparks
and all the things he's observed about
lightning and figures out
the lightning rod and that's how
jennifer doudna looks at this
mysterious way that bacteria fight
virus attacks and says let me figure out
why does it work
and i want to underscore how important
this is
and i say that speaking of someone who
has had to learn this over
time with respect to basic science and
as someone who funds a lot of science
right now a lot of scientific research
that
it is sometimes a mistake to be in a
rush to force the application or to
insist on an application
those applications some of the most
important discoveries
that have ever been made in human
history and
gene editing crispr may certainly be one
of them
have come about as as emergent from
basic science i just think that's so
important from a funding perspective
from a
sort of scientific literacy perspective
so i'm really glad we're talking about
it
so let's talk about something a little
uh more i don't want to call it crass
but uh human competition jennifer and
is it emmanuel am i getting that right
uh manual sharpen jay yes
yes go from observation to
in a sense having in their hand a tool
and whether they are motivated
or not by prestige or money they're
smart enough to realize that they are
sitting on something
very very potentially important and
massively impactful
can you describe the race that it that
ensues
i love competition just like most of
your listeners probably do and i think
competition
spurs us to go faster aim higher
do amazing things and part of
competition is racing
both to get the credit for something and
sometimes to get the intellectual
property the patents for something so
that you can
fund your research so when jennifer
dowden and emmanuel sharpentay discover
that this system bacteria have been
using to fight
viruses can be used as a tool by
us to edit our own genes
they get into a race or jennifer doudna
gets into a race
with other scientists to say okay let's
show how we can do that in a living
human cell because she had done it in a
test tube the question is
will it actually work if we try to do it
in the cell
of a living being like us
and the strongest competitors
are jennifer doudna at berkeley on one
side
and this wonderful guy named fong zhang
born in china but raised in iowa and has
sort of a corn-fed smile and enthusiasm
and he's at the broad institute of mit
and harvard
and so for six months they along with
some other scientists
race to see who can be the first
to prove that this amazing new tool will
actually work
in human cells and fong jiang wins the
race
by about a couple of weeks in other
words he publishes in january 2013
and jennifer doudna publishes at the end
of january 2013.
and they've been locked in a patent
battle ever since and people say in that
horrible
i say no this is why competition
spurs us to do good things but here's
something cool
both of them have turned their attention
in the past
year to using these technologies
to fight the coronavirus just like
bacteria use it
to fight viruses they use it to detect
the virus
and this time around they're racing to
publish papers on it
but they're putting them in the public
domain they're allowing people to use
whatever they discover
if they're using it to fight the
coronavirus so sometimes you have to be
competitive
sometimes you have to be cooperative
sometimes you have to try to
invent things that you get you know the
patents to and sometimes you put things
in the public domain
there's no one easy answer and i hate
people have
knee-jerk reactions that they hate all
patents or they think all patents should
be enforced forever
it should be like in your town of austin
and all when texas instruments does the
microchip
and bob noyce does a microchip
eventually they shake hands and say
let's make this useful for the world so
i'd love to just
bring up a number of points i think that
surfaced in what you just said
one of them relates to scientific
funding for people who don't know
performing science it can be extremely
expensive
very often is extremely expensive it
takes a lot of money
and one of the mechanisms by which
scientists can
fund their research because it requires
funding
requires people requires space it
requires tools
very often is with technology transfer
so within
universities many universities certainly
at places like
mit harvard et cetera you will have
technology transfer
offices and the university will license
technologies
and if the researchers involved
have intellectual property they're
sometimes able to
take a portion of those proceeds and
use it to allow them to continue their
research or do
new expanded more ambitious uh studies
in research so i just wanted to
mention that profit is not always a bad
thing money is not always a bad thing in
fact it is most often a necessary
component of of scientific breakthroughs
in this day
and age we would not have vaccines
against coronavirus had there not
been a race to understand how rna
can be a messenger in our body to make
protein
something that everybody from jennifer
doubted to a group at the university of
pennsylvania
did so well is figure these things out
and figuring it out is not something you
can do
in a dorm room like inventing facebook
or inventing
you know an algorithm for google or
something
it's something that takes a lot of lab
space and a lot of investment
so we have to have a system in which
discoveries are used for the common good
but also
people can benefit from having made
discoveries
and use the proceeds in order to fund
their research
you're here humans present company
included
respond to incentives human behavior in
a lot of ways is the study of incentives
and in animal behavior any behavior
really
and it's important to recognize that
scientists
also need resources i try very hard to
say what are those motivations
now look at jennifer doudna and fong
jiang and the others who have done it
and i don't think money is the main
motivator but it does
fund the research i also think you know
a claim people just want people to say
wow congratulations you did something
or better yet give them the nobel prize
for having done some
that motivates them as well but the
thing i've discovered about the
scientists in this book
is that they're also just motivated by
curiosity
and the belief that science is a noble
endeavor
it will make our lives better and
i believe that sort of at the beginning
of the book but then when i watch the
coronavirus hit
and i watch how people have been cured
of things like sickle cell anemia
by crispr the gene editing tool i
realized that
more than most people scientists have a
whole group of motivations but that
noble endeavor
of making the world a better place is
certainly
one of the main ones i'd love to
come back to covid or more accurately
to pandemics
for a moment and so to do a
retrospective
and then perhaps explore a bit of
forward-looking subjects so the
the please correct me if i'm wrong have
you interviewed the author of
the great influenza subtitle the epic
story of the deadliest plague in history
not only if i interviewed him i live
here in the french quarter and if i
craned my neck enough i'd see john
barry's house some on royal street
he's actually a couple blocks away i
think on burgundy street
but i run into john all the time just
ran into him and walking back from the
gym in the french quarter so
i love john barry's work it's great
narrative history
what have you learned from him or his
his work i know that's a very broad
question
but what are some of the the insights
or counter-intuitive learnings
or memorable points that come to mind
when i ask that question
when i read about the 1918 pandemic that
epidemic that john barry wrote about the
first thing i marvel at
is how little things have changed i mean
there they are trying to call
off parades in philadelphia or wearing
masks and getting people to wear mass
and social distancing
the same sort of things we've been
wrestling with for the past
year but the thing that impresses me now
is that we've invented a new type of
vaccine
back in 1918 vaccinations were pretty
rudimentary
you know they were done the same way
that edward jenner did a century earlier
which is to give you some facsimile
of the virus or bacteria you were trying
to fight see if your antibodies would
do so but now along with people like
jennifer doudna and other code breakers
we've invented a way to have rna
tell ourselves build these
antigens that will fight the virus so
suddenly we've had a quantum leap
so that the human species in its
hundred thousand year war against
viruses
now suddenly is taking the lead
and might be able to beat back pandemics
in the future
let's hop not to continue to bring it
back to this but to
sort of moral concerns you mentioned
doudna and her dream of
of of hitler and i mentioned albert
hoffman
earlier who synthesized lsd
was the first to consume it as a
synthetic at least
and the title of one of his books was
lsd
subtitle my problem child
and yeah he had he had a lot of thoughts
on the applications and misapplications
certainly that's true for a lot of the
scientists who worked on the manhattan
project and
and nuclear weapons what scenarios
or possible events
keep jennifer up at night or sit in her
mind
if you know or could speculate yes
there's a whole
part of my book the last quarter of my
book besides dealing with fighting the
coronavirus
deals with jennifer doudna and her
friends and colleagues
wrestling with what are the moral
implications
and as with any technology whether it be
the atom bomb or facebook
you know how we use that technology can
be for good or for
bad and so jennifer doudna
is wrestling with how do we make rules
of the road
and guidelines that we can agree to
internationally she
creates summits of a scientist
internationally to say
here's how we're going to use it for the
time being
at least and they've agreed to certain
rules which is
you only can should use it when it's
truly
medically necessary in other words if
it's the best possible way to fight
huntington's or sickle cell anemia and
that's
medically necessary then it makes sense
to use it
but you don't use it for unnecessary
enhancements like let's make our kids
taller or let's change their hair color
and i think as we go along we're going
to have to feel our way
which is why in the book i spend
time looking step by step
how they've gone through the different
moral issues and then
having our own thought experiments well
we can figure out what would happen if
we went into a fertility clinic
and they gave us a menu of things we
could choose
what would we choose and then think
about the downsides if everybody
gets or all rich people get to make
those choices
so it's not uh you know a one sentence
answer
for how should we use this technology
it's going to be something that over the
next
20 years we and our children and our
grandchildren are going to have to
appreciate how cool and wonderful
genetic editing can be
but also how we have to have some
guidelines
do you have any thoughts or have you
heard any thoughts on how we can create
guidelines that are actually
enforceable in a sense and you know i
don't want to say
i don't want to sound too much like you
know hobbes and leviathan or anything
like that but
in contrast to some of my friends i tend
to have a skeptical view of
sort of the altruistic default of human
nature and
i i i'm very interested
in how we can create sort of systems
instead of depending on best intentions
because there's so many motivations that
can warp best intentions
even the best of intentions do you have
any thoughts on
what maybe instead of guidelines guide
rails
can be established in in any way i think
it's going to be
hard to enforce too many guidelines
because unlike the atom bomb which i
could not make in my basement or even in
my
tulane university labs or something
crispr is something that is relatively
easy to do as we said the rogue
scientists in china did it two years ago
and edited the embryos of babies and
even i went to berkeley to jennifer
doudna's lab
and have a chapter where i am taught how
to edit
the genes of a human cell
now lest you worry about it once i
finished we flushed it down a drain with
a lot of chlorine
so i didn't create some frankenstein's
monster but it's something any graduate
student in biology could do and
eventually we'll find ways to deliver
those edits
more safely into human beings so it's
going to be hard to enforce it
but they're things that are hard to
enforce whether it be
the trafficking and elephant tusks or
for that matter sex trafficking or
shoplifting or running red lights but
as societies we find ways not that we
can
ban it entirely but we find ways to make
it something that's illegal to do
is hard to do is shameful to do
and a few people might break those laws
but at least we can keep it under
control and i think that's what we're
going to have to do
with the bad uses of gene editing
technology and that's what jennifer
doudna
wrestles with how do we create those
guidelines
and try to find some ways we can have
some good
enforcement of them if you had to choose
an aspect of the book an aspect of this
technology or the story
that you think people might not
pay enough attention to right there's
certain things that i think no doubt you
communicate
very very clearly and perhaps there's
something
that you worry people might miss
because it's not a huge feature in the
book but nonetheless very important is
there anything like that
the big thing i fear that people might
miss
is that if you don't read the book you
might have a knee-jerk reaction
just like people have to genetically
modified
organisms or you know food or corn
that's
been genet you know gmos those type of
things
and it's fine to have a strong opinion
about
gmos but it's also useful to know what a
gene
is before you have such a strong opinion
and i would hope that people keep an
open mind
just like great scientists and great
people who are curious and creative
they keep an open mind because there are
both good
and bad things that can come with this
but mainly good
things and so we shouldn't have a
knee-jerk reaction
and say oh this is horrible we're
playing god
we're messing with mother nature well
you know
if you want to talk about playing god
nature and nature's god have created a
species
that has evolved enough to learn how to
influence
its own genetic evolution and that
species is us
so this is natural that we have learned
these things
and we shouldn't have knee-jerk
reactions to it
based on not understanding it
and so i hope people will reserve
judgment
on what type of genetic editing what
type of vaccines
what type of uses we should do with our
molecules in order to fight
viruses not have a knee-jerk reaction
until you see the wonders of the
exploration
and keep an open mind about how the
technology can be used for
really great things like alleviating
suffering
and also potentially be used by people
with less good intentions
and i would add to that thank you for
saying all that and answering the
question
and i would add to that that whether you
like something or not
is oftentimes kind of irrelevant in the
sense that
if it is and it is not going to go back
to
is not then particularly when it has the
culture-shaping arc of
history bending potential of something
like this i feel like it is
certainly helpful and in some ways
incumbent upon us to
have a basic understanding if we can
develop such an understanding of
something like crispr i mean
it is not to overstate the case but i
think we will look
back at this kind of
with that promethean perspective
that you mentioned earlier absolutely
this is the most
important invention of our time
i think the ability to edit our genes
and to program our molecules to do
things like
create immunity to viruses
and like any technology it can be used
for good or for bad and
i think we have to understand it
so that we can all have a conversation
about it and we should be open to
the beauties and the wonders that got us
there
uh you know sometimes uh
our moral thinking has trouble
keeping up with our discoveries that
happened with the atom bomb
and then we had to say okay now let's
wrestle with it morally after we dropped
it twice
that frankly in my mind has happened
with social networks
where it kind of got ahead of our moral
thinking
about how can these best be used to
connect us
as a society so if we're going to keep
our moral thinking aligned
with our new discoveries and innovations
we have to understand those new
discoveries and innovations
and we have to know the story behind
them we have to ask the question
that you ask all the time which is why
why yeah it's and why not
also it strikes me that you never before
have the questions of philosophy that
might have been considered entertaining
thought exercises
for freshman philosophy 101 never before
have they been so incredibly important
and of practical implication
if you look at ai if you look at
programming autonomous vehicles to
say have to choose between hitting two
children on the sidewalk versus
three adults in the road that is a
decision that this car you know the
programming needs to
be able to make and with crispr
similarly many of these philosophical
questions are no longer
abstract discussions over a bottle of
wine
that they actually are pressing in some
respects
i think these are the questions we're
gonna have to face in the next
20 years so it's good to start
understanding
how it happened now and i love the fact
that you say it's not just
questions of why but also questions of
why not when i was writing this book as
i got near the end and when jennifer
doudna was thinking through the moral
issues
she not only asked why would we do
something like that
but after a while when people who have
kids with you know
problematic genetic defects or horrible
uh you know conditions such as
huntington's or
sickle cell she'd say well why not
fix it wouldn't we consider it immoral
not to be using this new technology
so we don't have to just ask why would
we use the new technology
but sometimes we have to say why not
wouldn't there be something morally
wrong
about not helping to cure people even if
it means
we're doing it through genetic editing
walter
i think this is a great place to begin
to wrap up i always have so much fun
in our conversations and uh
is there is there anything that you
would like to
add any closing comments questions to
pose to my audience requests to make of
my audience anything at all that you'd
like to
to add before we slowly wind this to a
close
i think the one request is
to help get everyone to understand
the nobility and the beauty of
science and open inquiry but then also
being able to walk into the future
into this mysterious new room we're
about to enter
with a sense of hope and optimism so
that we can
figure it out step by step cautiously so
it doesn't become a slippery slope
slopes are less slippery if we do it
step by step
hand in hand and i think that's what
we're going to have to do
as we watch this new biotech revolution
help us make our own molecules into
microchips that we get to program
walter isaacson i want to take your
class sir
you my class is online
it's on youtube if you can find it we
all link to it
welcome to austin too and we'll hear
some good music we'll eat some good food
we'll have a home and away games i'll
listen to some austin music and you can
you can come here some funk and jazz
here in the french quarter
i would love that and walter
thank you for the time your newest book
for everyone
listening is the code breaker subtitle
jennifer doudna gene editing and the
future of the human race
you can find walter isaacson.tulane.edu
and uh the the gumbo and some coffee and
some music as a date
good sir thank you very much
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little more soul of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the uh the world of the esoteric as i
do it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off
for the weekend so if you want to
receive that check it out
just go to 4hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
eight sleep my god am i in love with
eight sleep
good sleep is the ultimate game changer
more than 30 percent of americans
struggle with sleep
and i'm a member of that sad roof
temperature is one of the main causes of
poor sleep and heat has always been my
nemesis
i've suffered for decades tossing and
turning throwing blankets off putting
them back
on and repeating ad nauseam but now i am
falling asleep
in record time faster than ever why
because i'm using a simple device
called the pod pro cover by eight sleep
it's the easiest
and fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature it pairs dynamic cooling and
heating with biometric tracking to offer
the most advanced
but most user-friendly solution on the
market
i polled all of you guys on social media
about the best tools
for sleep enhancing sleep and
aidsleep was by far and away the crowd
favorite i mean people were just raving
fans of this
so i used it and here we are add the pod
pro cover to your current mattress
and start sleeping as cool as 55 degrees
fahrenheit or as hot as 110 degrees
fahrenheit
it also splits your bed in half so your
partner can choose a totally different
temperature
my girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need
cooling she loves the heat and we can
have our own bespoke temperatures
on either side which is exactly what
we're doing now for me
and for many people the result eight
sleep users fall asleep up to 32
faster reduce sleep interruptions by up
to 40
and get more restful sleep overall i can
personally attest to this because i
track it in all sorts of ways
it's the total solution for enhanced
recovery so you can take on the next day
feeling refreshed and now my dear
listeners that's you guys
you can get 250 off of the pod pro cover
that's a lot
simply go to eight sleep dot com slash
tim or use code
tim that's eight all spelled out
e-i-g-h-t
sleep dot com slash tim or use
coupon code tim t-i-m eight sleep dot
com
slash tim for 200 off your pod pro cover
this episode is brought to you by magic
spoon magic spoon is a brand new cereal
that i eat just about every day that is
low carb high protein and zero
sugar i just ate a huge bowl of their
cocoa flavor
about an hour ago after a short workout
magic spoon cereal
has received a lot of attention since
launching last year
time magazine included it in their list
of best inventions of 2019
and forbes called it the future of
cereal it tastes just like your favorite
sugary cereal from childhood remember
that
but it's actually good for you each
serving has 11 grams of protein
3 grams of net carbs 0 grams of sugar
and only 110 calories it's also gluten
free grain free keto friendly soy free
and
gmo free all the things it's delicious
and i don't say that lightly because
most of this healthy
version of x stuff is not delicious but
these guys really nail it magic spoon
has nailed it it comes in your favorite
traditional
cereal flavors like cocoa frosted and
blueberry you can try them all by
grabbing a variety pack
at magicspoon.comtim or you can just
grab a box
or a bunch of boxes i'm going to order
some more today of
the cocoa which is my personal favorite
but there is a new
contender for favorite flavor because
they just
launched two limited edition flavors
honey nut and peanut butter which are
delicious i am a sucker for peanut
butter
and it is outstanding so i think cocoa
and peanut butter are my two new
favorite flavors
and fun fact my friends are also
obsessed
with magic spoon one of the podcasts
most popular guest
dr peter tia routinely crushes six to
seven servings at a time that's a lot
with no glycemic response he's looked at
this with a glucometer
he likes it so much he invested other
friends two
very fine gentlemen and also past
podcast guests kevin rose and ryan
holiday
also invested so go to magicspoon.com
tim to grab some delicious cereal and
try it for yourself today
use promo code tim that's tim at
checkout to save five dollars off of
your order
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product i have boxes and boxes and boxes
it's backed
with a 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money
no questions asked get your next
delicious bowl
of guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
tim and use the code tim to get five
dollars off
[Applause]